[موسيقى]
احنا كعرب دائما بنربط الاكل بكل شيء وانا
تربيت مع عيله بتحب تاكل وبتحب الاكل
وبتحب تطبخ وبتحب تتجمع ودائما بثقافتنا
احنا مش بس الفلسطينيه العربي بشكل عام
انه بالفرح في صحن للفرح وبالحزن في صحن
الحزن وبيكون مناسبه في صحن
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي ساره عقل فلسطينيه اردنيه عمري
27 سنه مقيمه في دبي وانا عمري 13 سنه كنت
عامله مع اصحابي بعد المدرسه نعمل ساندوي
كتير صغيره ل80 شخص و70 شخص وقررت انه هاي
هي مايكل
وهميه بلشت
تبعتي
عملتها بعد ما تخرجت من الاكاديميه
الملكيه لفنون الطهي وبعدين اجيت على دبي
اشتغلت في اكثر من مكان ببرج العرب
بقياده بنات بالشرق الاوسط
وكان اسمه فيديا في دبي بعد كم من شهر
جوائز وانا انا اخذنا
حاليا بشتغل على مشروعين واحد بدبي وواحد
بعمان حاليا لتابل هو كونسبت بتغير كل
ثلاث شهور وعم نعمل من ايطاليه انجليزي
فلسطينيه او انجليا بلاد الشام
وبحب مرات اخلط انجليزي
كلياتنا بنعرفها في عنا صحن
اسمه باريس
يعني هي سندويشه
بس احنا عاملينها بخبز فلسطيني خبز
فلسطيني كتير زاكي
انا بكل مطعم بروحو وكل مطعم فتحته تقريبا
او كل مطعم كان الي ايد فيه بحط سلطه
بندوره
[موسيقى]
بحب انه ارجع على عمان وبحب الناس ايش
عندك عمان
هو داره عقل هو احتفال بكل شيء لكن هو
احتفال باحنا ايش ايش عندنا في البلد
كثير مهم الواحد يتذكر وين مسقط راسه كتير
مهم انه نحب ومن وين اجينا
بسيئاته وبحسناته ونشوف الاشياء الايجابيه
في اكثر بكثير من الاشياء السلبيه كتير
مهم
للجيل اللي جاي
[تصفيق]